in honor of feminism um
two women got kicked out of my shows
this weekend oh no way yeah what
they were wasted dude yeah something
about you know after 9 30 women and
women in charlotte
no okay
actually that's a
sweeping generalization yeah no because
actually all the women in the venue were
totally kept their liquor there was one
girl at one of my show the late show
on the last night
she was [ __ ] hammered just i looked
at the right of the stage like it's just
glass in her eyeballs but she stayed at
it the whole time
it's just looking at the back of my head
because of the way the seats were she
was like
i felt bad she just had like a she oh
she could see is my elbow okay
but one girl
i'm like just going you know i'm just
talking my [ __ ]
and then the context of one part of the
set is like i'm talking about how much
of an [ __ ] i am
and she goes
you're the [ __ ] noel and i go i know
dumbass i wrote the bible the premise of
the joke
and then i was like god damn that [ __ ]
hit you late didn't it and like it's the
percocet i'm just like [ __ ] you know
roasting her and then i start going
through the show and then she just
starts getting into it
with some of the wait staff because
someone walks by and catches her like
recording my set so they grab her phone
they delete it you know they make sure
it's deleted and she's gets really upset
she's like i just [ __ ] yeah
as they're walking her out
she's wearing heels so she didn't have
any grip on her heels so the heel slid
and she literally face plants
on the ground and everyone's like oh
and they help her up like are you okay
and i guess you know she's trying to
save face and she just starts trying to
like fight
one of the dudes helping her like
straight up like swinging
and then another way staff comes out and
she says oh this [ __ ] is not happening
here and she just like like locks the
girl up and drags her out of the venue
yeah no way people were like that is at
the some people the venue were like
that's the craziest
i've ever seen
anyone at the venue
the weirdest thing that i've noticed now
about doing clubs is that people go to
comedy shows just to get wasted like
it's a bar and it makes no sense to me
yeah yeah because there's there's such a
uh like watching a live performance
like
even broadway for example you know your
big broadway game oh huge yeah oh my god
did you see that sorry
just quick tangent of course did you see
that dude
um who posted a tick tock that the
he made a song
and it was he's like a comedy rapper and
he was auditioning for snl
yes this is awesome
yeah can you find it can we watch that
after
we did
i want to be the next snl cast member
and here's why i should be a contender
hi lauren michaels i'm jake novak and i
know that you're feeling the heat
because your roster lost cake kyle 80 mp
that means you got an open seat and i
feel loud to be feeling it cause when it
comes to comedy songs i kind of been
killing it see weekly music videos i'm a
jam bruh i'm a rapid rhyming hammy nerd
like lin-manuel miranda mixed with sammy
burke but haven't you heard i'm more
than a rapper i'm an actor too so here's
a couple of nice guys
it's after you after you after you after
you after you after you've seen that
scene i mean i meant right but i've been
sitting on the ringer in addition to the
spitting i'm a hell of a singer i could
be bouncing out on broadway but i'm
running for the 30 rock
[Music]
uh not literally obviously i just i
really want to give you the next big
thing
oh god dear mr michaels won't you give
me a chance
all right i'll perform man i'll sweep
the stage but whatever it is i'm ready
to do it in studio 8h what do you say
did i die or get you to bite maybe we
could try it live on a saturday night so
check my feed you'll agree where i
should be in september right with colin
keen and chloe and bowen as an snl cast
member
honestly i think if they hired him it
would be an upgrade
for snl you think
no yeah
no no we said yeah yeah yeah another one
we said one
what's this one about oh this is a yeah
this is the um
this is a commentary on gun violence
yeah okay yeah
yeah no go ahead jake
because it's not all jokes land of the
free home of the brave land of the ar-15
home of kids in the grave i've struggled
to find the words keep the disposition
sunny i'm always trying to turn the
unfunny things funny but laughing feels
wrong hypocrisy's rife i gotta say
something cause you're all pro-life
unless it's taken by a gunman nineteen
more tiny heartbeats stopped in their
alma mater you force kids into the world
then condemn them to
i guess we should announce now that jake
novak is actually taking he's
writing all the new tmg music and
actually he'll be performing it as well
we're actually uh licensing out the
brand and everything to him and he'll be
picking up where we left off that you've
all day one that's our new single yeah
that was a bit of a teaser at the top of
the episode when i asked cody what his
thoughts were yeah exactly yeah yeah
you've all these nuts oh i know i was
i was
i that thought crossed my brain but i
was like i would never say that
i just
objectively it is
it is usable
objectively
objectively i'm just saying
it exists it it does factual not funny
factually you can you've all these nuts
in your mouth
factually you can
it was a city before the tragedy guys
that's that's true and girls and
whatever you are okay
it was a city before the tragedy
occurred okay
digging yourself deeper i'm already
going to hell i it's i it doesn't matter
when i when i it's so funny
the just the in my mind i was like [ __ ]
that's so bad that's such a bad [ __ ]
then you've already
heard it come out it wouldn't be bad if
i i was like did i say it
it would be bad if i did that after it
happened and i was asking people did you
hear what hap you know
if i actually acted on
that would be horrible i didn't do that
okay
i'm a [ __ ] anthropologist in this
context okay
i'm just pointing out
this nomenclature that we've developed
is usable
as a deez nuts okay
all right oh my god
oh jesus i'm a historian of sorts okay
i'm just documenting that's what this is
this is this podcast is now an archive
of these nuts it is it is yeah that's
very true
we do tend to unearth a lot of them yeah
and that was an example of that that is
one discovery
it's an exploration it's a it's a
tasteless one to use oh yeah i would
never use it you should never no no you
should never
but can you you could you could
you can
you could
you can
you can you can you can you can
you can
so um there would be one you could do it
to the cops
oh that would probably be appropriate ah
yes
yeah that would be you could
that would be appropriate yeah the
sheriffs who did nothing
get pulled over on purpose say do you
know how fast you're sorry sorry officer
excuse me sheriff a quick question is
this evoldi's
um
yes obviously
oh
oh i thought of a really bad one right
there no
you've all these kids you left out
you've all these kids you left
unprotected
my guy yeah that probably puts you in
the slammer for sure yeah yeah yeah they
probably take you away instantly
you